hi friends my name is Chris this is
modern wisdom and it's finally that time
today you're going to learn everything
there is to know about the application
process and my best advice for getting
on the UK's biggest reality TV show love
Island if you are new here press the
subscribe button and once this video is
finished go and watch what it's really
like living on love island to find out
all the secrets from behind the scenes
to give you some perspective Oxford and
Cambridge get 36,000 applications every
year in 2018 love Island received 80,000
although there aren't any cheat codes to
beat the application process there are
some best practices which you can follow
I was the first person through the love
island villa doors on season 1 and I
probably didn't have any right to be
there but with a bit of clever
presentation and understanding of what
the producers wanted I managed to get
myself on the love island and take me
out within the space of two years I'm
not guaranteeing you'll get on the show
with this advice and I'm not claiming
that getting on love island is something
everyone should aspire to achieve and
I'm not saying that manipulating the
application process is the most virtuous
way to get on the show obviously the
whole point of the casting process is so
that the producers find people who are
naturally appropriate characters that
being said with a little bit of clever
strategy and a good understanding of the
process you can put yourself across in
the best possible light to the execs
however if this does lead to you getting
on the show please feel free to credit
me with your success and pay any
attempts anchor of any money or needs
which you receive for the rest of time
some initial warnings number one ITV are
looking for people aged 18 plus so if
you are 12 with dreams of being on
reality TV then that's great but the
show is actually aired after your
bedtime so just leave it for a few years
number 2 do not post online about
applying tweeting just applied to be on
live Island lull is a one-way ticket to
ITV saying no to you the whole concept
of the show is that the press and the
cast members do not know who is going on
before the show starts so posting about
it is just highlighting the fact that
you're a [ __ ] who can't keep the mouth
shut
number 3 if you've got a girlfriend or a
boyfriend and your plan is to dump them
a week before you go on the UK press
we'll find out and make you look like a
a massive massive being honest if you're
even planning on applying to a dating
show while you're in a relationship it's
probably a warning sign so maybe you
love island is perfect for you and you
should just dump them now and finally
number four if you have [ __ ] loads of
nudes or a sex tape floating around in a
group chat the chance of these being
leaked is almost 100 percent which is
totally fine if you don't mind your mum
seeing but if your head game is weak it
might be worth reconsidering the
application process is split down into
three main sections the initial
application form the first screen test
with an assistant producer or a casting
producer and the second screen test in
London in front of the exec producers
there may be telephone interviews and
other elements between all lists but the
strategy remains the same as a general
rule of thumb you want to be as truthful
as possible if you create a persona
during your application which you can't
live up to on the show you're going to
get found out very quickly
feel free to gloss over areas of your
life which you'd rather not mention but
don't make stuff up lies of omission are
easier to stick to than lies of
comission we'll get into strategies for
each stage in a second but throughout
each step you need to be thinking about
what the producers want from a character
they obviously want someone who's going
to get involved and create storylines
this is referred to as creating content
the more content you are likely to
produce on the show the bigger your
contribution and the more likely they
are to choose you this doesn't mean
being the loudest person in the room
it's love island not x on the beach but
you do need to show the producers that
you'll get involved first tip getting
noticed you can be as good of a
potential character as you want but if
no one knows you exist you're stood
outside in the cold on your own waving
your dick around hoping that someone's
going to see you it's going to be easier
to get on reality TV if you're highly
visible online having a couple of
thousand followers on Instagram is a
good place to start for a number of
reasons firstly lots of casting
companies scour social media for
potential applicants and the more well
exposed you are online the better this
chance will be secondly like it or not
you're following on social media is
interpreted as a ubiquitous
internationally recognised form of
social currency it's not an indicator of
value but it is a representation of your
popularity so more is
never gonna be a bad thing first
impressions matter so well curated
social media feed is important an itv2
will check those 50 dog photos or the
video of you pushing a mate down the
street and a shopping trolley might be
funny to you but the executives I TV
probably don't really care really basic
stuff here will make a massive
difference keep you thought as well let
don't upload ones of you looking
battered at your Gran's 80th and avoid
getting your dick up tip number two the
ideal scenario is for the casting
researchers to come to you via DMS or if
you've got a friend who works at ITV or
once was on the show they may be able to
put you in touch with someone but if you
don't open applications have started now
through ITV's website and the link is in
the description below the first stage of
the process is the initial application
form this is here to give ITV a first
impression of you and your background
they'll use it to work out if you're in
the right age bracket if you're single
whether you have a criminal record and
if you can spell your name the studio
needs to filter out people who don't
meet the criteria that they cannot
compromise on I'd actually guess that
more people who apply probably aren't
valid applicants than ones who are as I
mentioned you need to be over 18 to be
accepted also based on the show's
history it's unlikely the itv2 will cast
anyone over the age of 32 so that in
mind first up and most importantly you
will be asked to upload a one-minute
video telling ITV why you think you
would be a great Islander this is new to
me as I got fast tracked through the
first stage when I applied but the
process for creating a good VT here is
the same as for the later screen tests
so now is a good time to get started the
biggest bit of advice I can give and
this applies to all the screen tests
actually is that your goal should be to
reduce the distance that the producers
need to jump in their minds to get from
the person who they see in front of them
and the cast member that they want on
the show this means if you start with
the processes which the show use in mind
you'll see much more like a ready-made
cast member for instance avoid wearing
big branding on your outfit as big
branding isn't allowed on the show don't
sweat too much as big batches of
swearing don't tend to get aired and
look straight down the lens of the
camera just like they do in the villa's
interview room etc etc etc if you're
actually a fan of the show or if you've
watched it before this should be pretty
easy some tips to make a good VT number
one most importantly ITV
will not accept videos with a filter on
so don't upload one of you with an angel
halo or dog ears or a [ __ ] rocket
coming out of your ass you're just gonna
waste their time number two
film it somewhere quiet and well-lit
ideally with you facing a big window for
as much natural light on your face as
you can number three using the
front-facing camera on your phone is
more than sufficient if it's in HD the
studio concerned with your content here
they're not expecting George [ __ ]
Lucas number four dress and style
yourself naturally think of going out
for a nice lunch date with a friend this
should be a polished typical
representation of you as a person so if
you never wear jewelry but appear on
your tape adorned like Ali G it's not
gonna work
getting on to the content of the tape I
would always open your tape with your
name your age what you do and your
location this is the staple VT intro and
it's also going to be the first words
that come out of your mouth on the shows
VT as well next up just get straight
into the meat of it I would make a great
Islander because this is the question
the ITV are asking you so prepare it
think about your qualities as a person
what you'd bring to the villa your
relationship aims perhaps mention your
relationship history a couple of quick
funny stories would be great but you've
got one minute so keep it short in terms
of editing iMovie on your phone can
stitch multiple scenes together so I'd
nail the intro as one scene and then
have multiple cracks at the personal
explanation until you're really happy
with it finally and maybe most
importantly express yourself naturally
by moving smiling laughing down the
camera talking down the pipe as it's
called is super difficult and it can
lead to people looking really stiff and
uncomfortable express things with your
hands laugh when you tell a funny story
smile Lots and focus your eyes on the
camera these will make you seem more
outgoing personable and confident again
just imagine that you're talking to a
friend and then turn your energy in your
animation up by about 20 percent
moving through the rest of the
application form you'll be asked to
upload a headshot photo a full-length
photo and you can upload three optional
photos as well the questions for the
main section of the application form are
here fairly straightforward stuff are
you single how long was your last
relationship it's
etc there's no cheat codes or secret
answers here
just aim to be brief truthful and
charming as best you can over the
Internet
200 words per answer is probably fine
the custom producers are reading a lot
of these applications so if you can keep
your answer short sweet and interesting
then you'll make their lives an awful
lot easier remember what you said on TV
tea and use that as inspiration in your
application finally there are some more
legal questions at the end
I'd advise not lying on these as you can
see the studio are asking about whether
you've got any skeletons in your closet
even at this stage so think carefully
about applying the only thing worse than
getting through to the final stages of
the application process and the studio
finding out is getting onto the show and
then the press finding out the next
stage of the application process is the
initial screen test if you've made it
this far you're probably in the top 1 or
2 percent of all applicants so it seems
realistic that you might actually have a
genuine shot there will be multiple
locations and dates across the country
this will probably be in March or April
time the screen tests will happen in a
hotel meeting rooms somewhere when you
arrive you'll get placed into a waiting
room with other applicants to fill out a
form and then you wait for your turn to
go into a separate room and go on camera
as I mentioned before your goal should
be to reduce the distance the producers
need to jump in their minds to envision
you being on the show
on top of that you need to be able to
respond to questions on the fly and now
you have to get used to putting the
interviewers question in your answer
this is a odd quirk of reality TV and
it's a big departure from how you'll
normally speak so the interview will ask
you a question like what sort of girls
do you go for but the interviewers voice
is never heard on the show so the cast
members have to get around this by
putting the question in their answer the
end result becomes sort of girls I go
for this isn't just reserved for your
time on the show you'll have to do this
during your screen test so if you're not
prepared for it it'll really trip you up
the questions you can expect will just
be
expansions of what you've already seen
on the application form what's your
dating history
how would your friends describe you what
your interests what
for in a partner etc etc if you prep
good answers for the application form
and remember your key points you'll be
fine in the screen test instead of
looking into the camera this screen test
will be conducted with you talking to an
exec just off-camera this is much easier
as you have a person to fix your eyes on
and get a reaction out of remember to
use your hands to illustrate points
avoid looking stale smile and laugh
wherever you can and speak clearly
there's no longer a 1 minute time limit
on the discussion here but I would
recommend keeping your answers short and
snappy your screen test will be edited
into two or three minutes of footage at
most and given to the producers in
London to watch so taking up valuable
time by telling in my new detail exactly
what your gym routine consists of is
probably not a good idea here we reach a
really key point about reality TV in
general which is that the producers and
the audience get limited exposure to the
cast meaning that they need to be able
to make inferences about your character
beyond what they see of you they need to
be able to predict how they can fill in
the gaps about parts of your personality
that they haven't seen this doesn't mean
that you need to be predictable and
one-dimensional but you do need to speak
clearly and have well-defined views if I
ask what kind of guys do you like and
you spend two minutes saying well not
really like you know kind of a bit sort
at all like not too tall like but you
know a bit sort tall okay you know kind
of this message and presentation does
not come across well on air a good way
to help fill out your character and keep
your answers short and sweet is to use
cliches like it or not the love island
is quite a cheesy show at times and that
means the cheesy answers fit right in
remember about reducing the distance in
the producers minds if you get asked
what happens if someone gets in your
face and you laugh and say I'm a lover
not a fighter the audience gets a really
polished and well-rounded answer some of
the things that I said in my VTS which
led the producers to believe I'd be
creating lots of content with things
like saying that lots of friends confide
in me and I really liked being an ear to
lean on but also I can't keep my mouth
shut some time
I love gossiping this isn't really very
true but it's difficult to disprove and
it immediately makes you think fantastic
there's bags of storylines coming out of
this guy who can't keep his [ __ ]
mouth shut
content saying that I normally play it
cool with girls and I'm not bothered
most of the time but when I fall I fall
hard and I can become quite defensive
and jealous content I always say I don't
get involved in drama but then I just
can't help myself from stirring the pot
when it kicks off content you get the
idea the final stage is the London
screen test you've made it to the big
time now there will be less than 100 to
200 people out of nearly a hundred
thousand years so it's time to get your
game face on ITV will ship you to London
probably in late April you'll meet the
exact producers in ITV's offices and do
an extended screen test with them it'll
involve digging down into more of the
details about personal storylines you've
brought up so far here they're gonna be
looking to see that you're not a
one-dimensional character and that
there's more to learn about you then can
be discovered in a couple of minutes on
tape you need some more funny or
embarrassing stories ready to go but
there's nothing wrong with going back
over what you've already said and adding
elements answers here obviously you can
afford to be a little bit longer and
more descriptive to that same day you'll
likely be sent to Harley Street for a
psychometric evaluation to check if you
have any mental health issues which
might become agitated by being on the
show you'll also be given a medical
examination including the most
comprehensive STI check you've ever seen
and some booster shots for things like
tetanus if yours have lapsed it's a very
bizarre but oddly quite nice experience
then it's just a waiting game to receive
the call during this time the execs may
FaceTime you and chase up some more
questions about you that they want more
info on this is also the stage where ITV
will be running they're very thorough
background checks so if you've got that
sex tape lurking around
it may be surfacing soon and that's
about it if you get the faded call from
the execs then congratulations welcome
to love island you're in the villa
please pass go please collect 1 million
followers
loads of
and a super drug sponsorship on the way
past if you have any more questions
about the process please throw them in
the comments below and if you've learned
anything or enjoyed the video please
give it a thumbs up there is enough
content to fill the love island pool
coming out of the next few months so
press subscribe it would make me very
happy indeed if you want to hear about
what life is really like in the love
island villa then press here and watch
our podcast episode which explain all of
the secrets from behind the scenes
[Music]